schifo leccato il microfono e a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo un video
sono poi giorgi siamo tornati su sixties
ecco perché hanno fatto un aggiornamento
è l'ultima volta che l'ho giocato è
stato tipo mesi fa avevo vinto
sottolineiamo sta roba mi andava di fare
un altro episodio così random una volta
ogni tanto mi capita di farlo dico va
bene la prima parte c'è un caldo bestia
e dalla vita che non lo faccio non mi
ricordo neanche più come si come si
gioca sa che vedo che hanno tradotto in
italiano la partenza è sempre quella
raccoglierle robe questo è il tempo che
ho per guardarmi in giro che il culo
quanta roba vicino di pulizia possa
uscire adesso la porta ma mi sa di no ha
detto prendiamo questo effetto cioè le
zuppe detto queste cose vicino quanto
cui ho avuto per averla partenza c'è
maicon tuo figlio ok torcia bravo porno
che bordello reca ogni volta sta parte
un calvario incredibile mia moglie serve
per forza da radio vai prendi a prendi
prendi la tua donna vai così mica mia
figlia che gigante non riesco a portarla
non ho preso provviste però rega tipo
non so se è ancora tempo per farcela
rega
[Musica]
che culo incredibile quando ma anche un
secondo la prima ora di italiano del
lunedì
beh almeno la scorta di zuppa che più o
meno la stessa gavetta a scuola nella
mensa niente partiamo ragazzi questa è
la prima volta che lo faccio senza sono
forte sono fortissimo battuto record del
mondo senza fare un cazzo bene stato un
fenomeno bene poi ripartiamo adesso
partiamo a caso io credo cliccato questo
ve lo giuro che non ho capito niente
però almeno design service se lo avessi
avuto una casa piccola e pavimenti noi
scivolosi va bene ma io volevo volevo
giocare con tutti non costituì dei
roditori mutanti stanno assaltando le
nostre provviste non è pietro quello
prova ben spara spara parte che non noi
col pd che spara fare un uso io da in
testa nostra latina sono salve il
peccato per il mutante peloso appunto
quindi era pietro a quanto pare ci siamo
ancora noi in cima alla catena
alimentare meglio così una credenza del
rifugio un po instabile così l'abbiamo
spostata per riposizionarle così abbiamo
scoperto una porta segreta dove conduce
torcia sicuro ci saranno provviste
convintissimo
ecco la mappa della città che culo
quindi ragazzi abbiamo la radio la mappa
perfetto per adesso ci siamo a non hanno
fame ancora vita sui passati cinque
giorni spiega non hanno ancora fame
cinque giorni senza mangiare o ben
contenti voi qualcuno sta bussando alla
porta con insistenza ma sai che ti dico
stavolta prova da principio ci provo ma
sti cazzi ma sti cazzi proprio passato
remoto rimasti cai ma come mia moglie
che sfiga partenza ok a partiti in due
sono ritornati in tre quindi molto
meglio nel mio figlio non si sanno è
finito la madonna e tipo l'insetto che
avevo in casa dell'anno scorso va beh
[Musica]
ne ho abbastanza di a coordinare
insapore dolores brama una tazza di
caffe il vero caffè americano quello che
non ti fa passare la stanchezza nemmeno
se bevi cinque tazze io l'ho provato
ragazzi mi fa cagare il caffè americano
c'è una roba forse qualcuno dovrebbe
intraprende una missione per il caffè
zia se vuoi prendere il caffè ci vai tu
nel senso cedevo manda un altro anzi
culetto trova a prendere se vuoi se ti
otto siti 6 ammalata mischiatti lì non
ti spiegano altro kit per te il nostro
volontario è tornato a mani vuote a
quanto pare il ristorante la solo un
triste buco nel terreno con qualche
sedia spazza intorno che delusione da
ricaduta radioattiva è quasi terminata
ora dovrebbe essere più sicuro viaggia
in superficie bene potrei adesso che le
radiazioni si sono abbassate ci conviene
mandare ted però deve tornare vivo
perché se non torni vivo sono nella
merda non possono andare in giro con
niente perché non ha la valigia porca
vacca bailly così haworth 17 lega ci ha
fatto visita un commerciante
dall'aspetto trasandato con una borsa
altrettanto malconcia in cambio di un
sola barattoli di zuppa riceveremo la
borsa e tutto ciò che contiene dovremmo
accettare l'offerta
ai ragazzi dico di sì tanto una zuppa
non ci cambia la partita in teoria che è
successo
c'era un gatto nella borsa si chiama
shari com non appena la porta si è
chiusa alle spalle commercianti alla
borsa iniziati a scuotere in modo
violente a emettere suoni striduli e
orribili impauriti ci siamo addossati ai
muri quando finalmente l'avesse si è
liberata è saltato fuori che era solo un
gatto domestico il collare c'è scritto
shari coop sarà il suo nome si ma non
mangi tua zubair tu vai magni da solo
ott emanavano è strano mary jane oggi
non ha parlato affatto forse qualcuno
dovrebbe capire cosa sta succedendo
no meglio lasciar perdere persone che
non parlano tipo la mattina e mi sveglio
non voglio che nessuno mi parli dovete
stare zitti quindi non abbiamo la palla
che cosa mi ci sta facendo quel ragazzo
è tutto scemo curioso sembra che
l'intero rifugio tremito ogni due minuti
ogni volta in maniera più forte ecco di
nuovo sempre peggio e un terremoto
teniamoci stretti qualcosa teniamoci
stretti a qualcosa vuol dire che quella
cosa che stringola salvo vuol dire che
si rompe allora ten distretto alla radio
teoria perfetto che è nullo riusciti a
salvare la radio che anche si
frantumasse a terra grazie a dio attende
sono venti giorni che fuori aiuto ma
hanno rigato non magna mentre cercavamo
di accarezzare quel diavoletto abbiamo
trovato un pezzo di carta sul suo
collare con scritto sopra un indirizzo è
possibile che si è vecchi padroni siano
ancora vivi un pensiero per lui è poco
probabile ma forse dovevo andare a
trovarli va bene dai provaci ormai sto
facendo le cose più strane raga le cose
che non farei è tornato ted dove è
andato il gatto abbiamo portato a casa
prima di raggiungere la fine della
nostra vita due uomini che indossavano
cappotti scuri e capelli alla moda ci
hanno fermato ci sono precipitati sul
gatto l'hanno preso in braccio e ci
hanno detto che lo cercavano da tempo
carico va a partire una vecchietta qui
manca tanto li vuole molto bene a me
l'ha mandato niente ma come la colla
riportato raggiunto bordello per
fottermi una cosa di zuppa è stato fuori
otto giorni e mi ha portato due
barattoli di zuppa perfetto porca vacca
rega che anzi asta prezzo giocando lì la
difficoltà molto più alta di quella
dell'altra volta e quindi in teoria
dovrebbe essere di base più difficile
madonna quanta provanti problemi hanno
questi questa c a qualsiasi che c'è pure
il ciclo già sembra che una mandria di
animali sta correndo sopra i nostri test
e su quello che una volta era il nostro
bel prato è un'ottima occasione per
procurarci un po di cibo fresco manda
mary jane dai stesso a prendere qualcosa
è morta scommettono ma no ma bastava dai
abbiamo trovato il branca siamo riusciti
a colpire una specie di asina due teste
che stava trasportando un pacco scaduto
poi di zuppe bene con nostra grande
sorpresa abbiamo trovato scarico non
siamo molto sicuri e il motivo come ce
l'abbia fatta ma è tornato c'è qualcuno
mi vuole spiegare cosa fa quel maledetto
gatto solo lei può andar fuori va bene
ti direi portati il gatto che è
divertente ma vai a mani nude perché non
c'è la valigia tante l'unica roba che ti
puoi portare
sarebbe la valigia del resto non ha
senso il gatto tra o rega sopravvive
solo il gatto ve lo dico io che sta
bussando mio dio
gli agenti che ci stavano spiando sono
alla porta e pare vogliono darci
spiegazioni agenti ascoltiamo gli agenti
salvagente da gente con tre facce che
voleva basta bussare erano interessati
al gatto ma che minchia sei una spia
russa tour intorno alle 3 di notte
durante uno dei suoi momenti di pazzia
carico si è schiantato di fascia contro
il muro da quel caduto un mattone
instabile dietro c'era una scatola di
sigari con all'interno delle munizioni
il gioco così sfogato assumere tutta
un'altra piega ed è allo stremo ted è
riposato beh sì coerente almeno apriti
in nome della libertà gridavano fuori
dalla porta
eravamo lì sicuri di chi fosse questa
presentate la libertà ma si capiva che
si trattava di un gruppo di persone
forse armate chiunque si presenta chiusi
sta lì certo progettando di uccidere
qualcuno in nome della libertà che si fa
sì sì sì sono vivi
incredibile abbiamo sbirciato fuori sono
stati salutati da un gruppo di liceali
charlie c artistico ci hanno dato una
grande i liceali bella li altro che itis
che si fanno tutti i cazzi loro
io ero dell'itis se c'erano gli
universitari erano ancora in ansia per
l'esame dopo tutto sto casino invece
c'erano i liceali grazie tornata la mia
moglie bene è difficile non preoccuparsi
che siano una sola
di una zuppa più una dama più una torcia
non ci servirà niente di tutto questo
servirà l'acqua gli agenti ci hanno
telefonato per la macchia g a quelli
prima per darci la prossima missione
segreta e ci assicurò un posto nel
bunker dei vip vogliono che portiamo a
termine una spedizione che ci scriviamo
quello che vedremo nel diario facile
come bere un bicchier d'acqua no va bene
mandate ho mandato a te ora cava che a
mia moglie morta o è tornato a ted è
successo alla mano niente raga in tutto
questo dobbiamo aspettare
che ci chiamino gli agenti per portarci
nel rifugio dei vip
perché non funziona non non ci salviamo
mai la penultima razione di acqua che mi
rimane poi non mi rimane un nono più
acqua che gli agenti sono tornati in
un'altra richiesta dobbiamo essere
generosi a fornire un paio di barattoli
di zuppa per un agente sul campo loro si
occuperanno della consegna e diamo il
gruppo rete dove non mi chieda aiuto e 4
spero mica quante gliene ai dati di
baratto di maledizione non ce l'ho più 4
nei dati multi veramente l'ultima scorta
di acqua non ho più niente che è
successo a con la parola solo bene in
tutto questo il gatto è a posto è il
gatto vive da dio sia presente sono
prossime al game over
sun tutti via schifo tranne il gatto e
gatto sta bene madonna regala fine
fantastico e molto ted eva se morite
definisce la partita non mi ricordavo
attorno a quanta roba questo sete fame
malattia in agonia pazza stanchezza
stremato guarda i video dimette bizet
tutto ciò 7 problemi questa donna va beh
il gatto ha posto un altro posto carico
corre salta privi funzionale trovato
abbiamo trovato una mappa in perfette
condizioni sarà anche datata ma ci
tornerà utile di sicuro è finita la
partita è niente oggi moriamo ne tragga
alla fine gli agenti ci hanno preso per
il culo gli ho dato le zuppe fatto
spedizioni di tutto siete morti il
compenso però prima ho vinto con un solo
round o troppo niente il suo gioco ora
però il gatto si è salvato almeno quello
quindi ragazzi io spero che vi sia
piaciuto ricordatevi di non ascoltare
persone che si fingono agenti quando vi
chiedono di fare delle cose per loro
perché sono degli scrocconi maledetti
come sa quanto mi piace anche la
descrizione sono state si scateni ci
vediamo al prossimo video
[Musica]